you are fighting alberto el patron as
they say his name burp a patron help but
it's wrong okay
thrown and he's he was a WWE guy but he
fought MMA first
yeah he's as a record actually a nine
and five he's fought and pride and oh
he's fought in Japan a bunch of times
former greco-roman all of us are not
Alypius uh medalist um he got some
background I watched him with Spain's
training stuff and
thank you come back the American I
appreciate it I gotta say thanks Alberto
for actually have enough balls to step
up and I wish is in here because I get
my standing ovation this guy has some
courage
you know this because this guy's a lion
I gotta give him the respect and I've
given the respect because I started my
camp like I said ten weeks ago I mean
I've been putting in the work I'm not
out you know having fun doing the Hoople
arm your training I'm training my butt
off man this is this is my life this is
what I do and this is what I love what
do you think the chances are that you
will not win this fight
there's always a chance I'm not gonna be
likes there's no chance in my mind
there's no chance in his mind they think
he has a chance I don't think he has a
chance mm-hmm I don't I don't view any
loss at all I don't be him touching me
I'm gonna punch him in his face I'm
gonna smash him I just that's the way I
train that's the way I am that's my
mindset you know I'm like an animal and
I step in the cage and so I've always
been I mean I put my heart and soul in
the gym I'm putting in you know anywhere
from six to eight hour days six days a
week this is my life my name my legacy
this is what I live for for almost 22
years now and I'm still doing it the
surgeries I've had athletes don't
compete and I'm still competing and it's
not him the factor of competing it's
another man is I'm training and I'm
doing the things that I've done so that
been 22 years old I'm 44 now and I'm
there I'm on point everything's great
tickets are on sale Friday by the way
October the 11th 10:00 a.m. I take it
master comm if you want to if you want
to go and obviously will be a
pay-per-view event on Saturday December
the 7th its from the the pain arena at
the us-mexico border and her dogs on the
border so this is one of those things
that Alberto Doria don't believe in
borders I am totally on the opposite
side I'm pro-trump on oh you are 100% is
it for tax reasons or for immigration or
both um it's for immigration it's for
safety of our country it's for the
protection or for our military finally
someone's out looking for the people of
our country and I believe in Donald I
work for Donald Trump back in 2005 on
the sly beer apprentice he's an honest
man he's a great man he's a very smart
businessman he's not a politician and I
think that's why people don't like him
because he's not a politician he's
looking for a country and this country
needs a business savvy person he is that
man and so you're working he'll for this
fight that is that's what is called
being an American as a heel that's him
I'm not to me oh I guess all the people
in Hollywood who are just too afraid to
speak up uh-huh I I have to be the hill
and to support our president and I'll be
the
it is funny - I'm an American at the end
the day when I go to bed
I want my kids to have safety in this
country and that's what's number one to
me it is funny how if you wear a mag
ahead or if you say anything supportive
about the president yeah like it's never
been like that in history where like if
you if you support the bush people like
is a Republican but if you support Trump
people somehow act like you're this
you're a criminal or like how like they
just can't get over the bank vault yeah
yeah it's a really crazy perception I
don't get it you know it seems like
people they want to help everybody else
but the country and I watched the debate
the democratic debate and they were
talking about other countries and other
people and how we need to take care of
them it's like what about us here in
America the enemy veterans are homeless
or have health issues and mental health
issues how many people have mental
health issues who are Americans why
don't we take care of our people first
that's what should be number one and
Trump is doing that Trump is trying to
do that but he just keeps getting
sideswiped by so many different stupid
things are just fabricated fake news I
think the press is fair to him um no now
you see only here's another thing - so
I'm not a person who sits there and goes
oh I'm just gonna watch Fox News all the
time no I watch CNN I watch all these
other media outlets and it is just it is
propaganda I watched and just like how
can you guys see it's miss things I just
I'm I'm baffled by it I mean are people
that uneducated to really understand
that I mean I believe on facts I want to
see facts I want to see him black and
white I want to see the proof of things
not with someone said of hearsay that's
BS that's mean that's a high school [ __ ]
I mean why do that let's go by what the
facts are what's the proof isn't what
he's doing for our economy that's
important what he's doing for our people
that's important and finally as the
president's not selling our country out
to the highest bidder I'm thankful for
that so when you had kids I used to
change the way you look at everything
right because like politics never Paul
2-person I never even cared about I
never even cared I mean yeah I still pay
fifty five percent of my taxes to the
country you know I'm I I mean I I paid a
big lump sum over a 20-year career I
twenty-year career all right look it's
like where my money going all of a
sudden they're right and you know it's
like was it four billion dollars to Iran
something like that I mean just these
numbers that were just over and I was
just an Offerman I'm like okay I'm gonna
start paying attention to this stuff and
seeing what is really happening where's
all my money go yeah yeah for the first
time in my life I actually voted I voted
for Donald Trump that was the first time
you never voted that first time I've
ever voted how did it feel going in for
the first I mean I've only heard it
twice a song oh but I mean how did it
feel going in for the feeling anything
made me feel proud it made me feel like
I was standing for our country you know
I'm a huge supporter of the troops I've
been to Iraq six times I've been to
Walter Reed Bethesda about seven I
probably visit overt gosh 30 bases
across the United States Japan Germany
Iraq Iran from a quoit border all the
way to the Turkish border I finished I
mean I'm each time I've done I visit
about 19 fob so I'm a huge supporter of
our troops and I just watch the things
that go through and hopefully trump will
bring them out when you go to the bases
to overseas you just kind of just hang
out it's like meet and greets and you
didn't just talk to people and you know
yeah I mean no god I have huge turnouts
when I go because I guess they get to
watch it on was it FS N or F F NS the
yeah the network this network yeah
course network and they all watch my
fights and they see me come walking out
with the American flag and you know it's
it's pretty cool it's just a the
exception or the acceptance I get from
the fans are from the troops it's just
amazing you know there are 2,500 people
of troops like waiting in line I can get
an autograph and talk with me and
they're so happy you showed up they're
like they're just happy that you're
there they're always the best it is like
what I'm able to sit down with the whole
squad of guys you know there's you know
two or three hundred guys and girls and
I'm able to have a conversation when I'm
talking about teamwork you know talking
about our battle and what it's like back
at home right now how do they feel and
for that 30 minutes or that hour I'm
with them they feel like they're at home
they don't realize they're in the
sandbox and they're just like I mean I
talked to some of the Colonel's they
pull me aside like Tito thank you for
coming
that was amazing these guys and girls
they they love it man they want to feel
like to be home and kind of boost him
around a little bit I think that's
really important and I think a lot of
that is lost where they come back home
they kind of feel like there's not
nothing
to really be accepted to they fought for
nothing they feel like and seeing people
burning flags and stomping on flags and
I mean it's just pretty sad right now
it's a country that I think needs to
come together and you know this fight
against Alberto Del Rio you know him
being from Mexico and now he's an
American citizen
maybe being I'm an American citizen born
and raised in California and I think
we're battle over some a little bigger
than just a fight you know I think we're
battling for the future over time
driving one more Jim and Sam catch up
with full episodes and interviews from
celebrity guests anytime on demand using
the Sirius XM f
[Music]